Hey What's up guys
Welcome to hajme world's
キラーン٩(๑´3｀๑)۶☆
名前の通りです
走る生放送カメラ
これ何かと言いますと
まさにそのとうりですね
車なんですけども
動かせて
で録画ができて
この車自体が遠隔操作で動かせるみたいです
おーすごいなー
遠隔操作ってどれぐらいまでいけるのかな
３０メートルか　うん...　もっとなんか
1キロとか2キロとか
おいらん家から遠く離れた場所の見たかったですね、
ひとまず開けてみましょう
うわ！！　ちゃんとこうカメラになってますね。　うわすごいな結構　本格的な気がする　いやーーー
悪さしてーな（ゲス顔
さあちょっとどんなものか調べてみようか
なるほどな ひとまずアプリをダウンロードしましょう
はい出ました
こちらですね
今のリフレッシュ
どういう事や
これは ただシンプルに追加を押すだけですね
これ、遠隔でコントロールできるのかな
どういう事なんだろう？
遠隔使ったら、どこでも できんのかな
遠隔で やってみるか
今、初期化中みたいです
何にもわかんなかったんだけど
まあ、いまからとりあえず出来たでしょう
はい、なんとか 登録することができました
こちらですね
これが、この車の信号らしいです
これで動けば一番いいんですけどね
きたきたきたきた
うわぁ　きた きた きたぁ！　すごい！　すごいけど大丈夫？
「すごいけど大丈夫？」
これはヒドイな！
なんか、通信が不安定だな、これは
いや、これ厳しいよ、ちょっと！
いちおう、来てるんですけど
これで、操作できるんですけど
全く反応しないです。
充電が足りないのもあるかもしれないけど
（はじめ）あいうえお
（機械）アイウエオ
声を真似する！
おい！！（ピー）すぞ！
（機械）おい！（ピー）すぞ！！
「はい、という訳で ちょっと充電がすくないみたいなので」
「一回かなり充電してみます」
はい、というわけで充電けっこう溜まりました
これで、操作性が良くなっていたら話は別だぜ
これで動くか
はわああ！！
動いた！
はぁ？
今の一瞬だけ？！
そんな、
ダ、ダ、ダ、チョーイ！！
マジで動かないんだけど！
あ！、今の、今の、今いい感じ
今いい感じじゃない？
今、ちゃんと動いているよ
今、ちゃんと顔認識しているけど
もう、こちょこちょ！
本当何かの
（小声）ミテミテミテ、見て！　スゴイ！
マスク置いた・・・ほら
マスク取った！
まずは何してみようか
座った、座りました
そして、もう一人お客さんが来ました
彼らは両方デュエリストです
あ、俺のデッキに手を伸ばして
盗もうとしているのか
（はじめ）「盗まないで」
（機械）「盗まないで」
（まさき）なに、これ？
動かします
クククッ　　　こ、コワっ！
がんばれ、ロボット
こんにちは、マサキ！
「こんにちは、MASAKI」
MASAKI: こんにちは～
体当たりしてみていいすか
ちょっと体当たりしてみましょう
こいつ、面白いですね
突撃してみよう
＊ね！　オラ！
クククッ
オラーっ！
メガネの方にも突撃してみましょう、次は
よし、クラっ、オラッ！
シー
大回転、花びら大回転やで、これ面白いな！
すごいね、これ！
お二人とも元気かい？
「二人とも、元気かい？」
うるさい
wwwww
「ED」♪〜
Translator: Exploding Gamezzz